[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في اخبار الساعه من
العربيه
الوسطى من داخل السودان
كبير المفاوضين الايرانيين يشددوا على
ضروره رفع العقوبات للوصول الى احياء
الاتفاق النووي
وزير الامن الاسرائيلي يقتحم باحات الاقصى
بدون اعلان مسبق والسلطه والفصائل تدين
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا البدايه من السودان
اغلاق حدود السودان مع افريقيا
مع افريقيا الوسطى
مشاهدينا معنا من يخلطوا مراسل العربيه
لينا يعقوب اهلا بكرينا لا تضعين في صوره
المشهد كاملا ما هي تفاصيل هذه المحاوله
الانقلابيه في افريقيا الوسطى التي كادت
ان تنفذ من داخل الاراضي السودانيه
احاديث
نائب رئيس مجلس اسياد محمد حمدان هو اليوم
الخامس الذي يبقى
يتحدث بصوره واضحه عن مجموعات تسعى لخلق
فتنه هذه الفتنه تتمثل في الاغتسال القبري
الذي يدور حاليا في داخوك وايضا محاوله
دخول افريقيا الوسطى لتغيير النظام حينما
يتحدث عن مجموعات يقصد عسكريين سابقين
هؤلاء العسكريين السابقين ربما كانوا في
الجيش السوداني ربما كانوا في الدعم
السريع وربما كانوا في حركات مشلحه اخرى
هؤلاء المجموعات همم اتجهت وكونت همم فرق
مسلحه ليه الدخول الى افريقيا الوسطى هو
اليوم يتحدث انه سيقومون بعمل معسكرين لضم
هذه المجموعات حتى لا تخلق ايضا الى حدود
اخرى مجاوره طبعا هو اليوم الخامس كما
ذكرنا فيه في كل يوم كان نائب رئيس مجلس
يتحدث عن الاشياء التي يتم القاء اليوم
فيها على الدعم السريع بصوره واضحه من
بينها خلق الفتنه والفوضى وزياده الاغتسال
القبلي
ربما يكون البيان السادس نحن نكون في يومه
الخامس بصوره واضحه هل توفرت معلومات عن
المنطقه التي جرى فيها اعتقال هذه او
هؤلاء الذين يرغبون في تنفيذ هذه المحاوله
الانقلابيه جنسيتهم اعدادهم ايضا لينا
القبائل هناك
الاعداد
التي حصلنا عليها انها تتراوح من 8000
جندي حتى 10,000 هم من كانوا يحاولون
الدخول الى افريقيا الغرب بحسب ايضا
المعلومات الحصول على الذهب وربما تعزيز
الحركه للدخول الى مناطق تنجيد الذهب داخل
افريقيا اوسطه ايضا حنيت يتحدث انه هناك
جهاز ترمي اليوم عليه
بالمتابعه ربما واضحا
اذا فقدنا الاتصال مع الجميع
والدخول الى دوله لاحداث تغيراتها هو
الامر الذي نفاه الان قائد الدعم السريع
بصوره واضحه
الى منطقه اخرى
هذا البيان الذي اعلنه اليوم نائب رئيس
مجلس السياده وتحدث فيه بصوره واضحه ان
هناك جهه تقوم بمد همم هؤلاء القواتي
الدعم الفريق ونحن نعلم ان الشركات تدفع
لان الجيش السوداني هي التي تقوم بعمل
الزير العسكري لذلك الان يعني تبدوا
الرؤيه ضبابيه قليلا من الذي هؤلاء الجنود
بملابس همم للدعم السريع وهو يتحدث عن
شركه موجوده
الى اي تطورات جديده حول هذا الموضوع شكرا
يتطورات الحرب الالكترونيه
بعيد المدى في منطقه العمليه العسكريه
الخاصه في مؤشر على تواجه موسكو نحو توسيع
حجم ونوعيه الهجوم الذي خلال المرحله
المقبله واعلن قائد الطيران الروسي بعيد
المدى سيرجيكو وبلاش ان الطائرات الحامله
للصواريخ الاستراتيجيه سوف تشارك في منطقه
العمليه العسكريه الخاصه في هذا العام
واضاف ان التركيز اساسيه خلال عمليات
تدريب الطيارين حالا يتجه الى تحسين مهاره
استخدام الاسلحه وانظمه القياده والتوجيه
الاليه هذا وارتفاع عدد قتل القذف
الاوكراني على دائره تجنيد روسيه في
دنياسك الى 78 جنديا مع اصابه
136 اخرين في واحده من اكثر الهجمات
الدمويه منذ بك الى عمليه العسكريه
الروسيه في اوكرانيا وتعاهد الكريم
للمشاهدين ايضا بعدم التهامي مع ما جرى
خصوصا وان القصوى استهدف نقطتين شعر مؤقته
لقوات المسلحه
وتم باربع صواريخ تحميل رؤوسا حربيه شديده
الانفجار من انعاء ذلك مشاهدينا قامت
القوات الروسيه بنشط طائرات بدون طيار
متفجره في محيط المنطقه المستهدفه واضافت
وزاره الدفاع ايضا ان طيرانها الحربي
استهدف نقاط انتشار مؤقت في دنياك وحركاب
ما خلف عشرات القتلى
الخطا الذي ارتكبه الجلود الروس انهم
يستخدموا هواتفهم المحموله في تقنيه
عسكريه حساسه غلطه جعلتهم صيدا ثمين
للقوات الاوكرانيه وكلفت الجيش الروسي
العشرات من القتل والجرح بين جنوده فيما
تقول كياب ان العدد اضعاف ما اولين عنه
تفوق
بل يفوقوا ما سجلته اذا همم في الجانب
الالكترونيه من حربها هذا يشكل تفوقا في
الجانب الالكترونيه من حرب ضد الروس
ضربه اوكرانيه دقيقه وموجعه ودميه قتل
وجرحى من الجنود الروسي
موسكو اقرت بمقتل 63 جنديا لكن كيف تقول
ان العدد اكبر من ذلك بكثير
الهجوم وقع في شرق اوكرانيا تحديدا بمدينه
مكيفكه شرقي دونيتسك التي تسيطر عليها
روسيا
اربعه صواريخ مارس ضربت مركز انتشار مؤقت
للجيش الروسي في المدينه العمليه العسكريه
نفذت بناء على معلومات استخباراتيه دقيقه
تقول مصادر مواليه في دونيتك ان استخدام
المجندين الروس الواصلين للتو الى المعسكر
لهاتفهم المحموله وبكافه سمح للجيش
الاوكراني بتحديد موقعهم الجغرافي خطا
روسي فادح وقاتل سبق ان تكرر في حرب
اوكرانيا فالقوات تعتمد بشكل متكرر على
اجهزه اتصالات وخطوط غير امنه او مؤمنه
كالهواتف المحموله واجهزه الراديو التي
تعمل بنظام الضغط للتحدث الهجوم الاخير
يعكس قدرا كبيرا من التقدم الاوكراني في
الحرب الالكترونيه بفضل بكياف بمعدات
غربيه متطوره
بحسب خبراء فان اوكرانيا استفاده من
الاتصالات الروسيه نفسها وحجزت اشارتها
واعمت رقابتها واستولت على بعض انظمه
الحرب الالكترونيه الاكثر تقدمها لكن ثم
من يرى ان القاده الروس العسكريين اخطاوا
حين افترضوا ان الجيش الاوكراني لم يتطور
كثيرا منذ عام 2015
كما اخطاوا حين تجاهلوا تاثير المعدات
الغربيه وتدريب النيكل الوحدات الاخرانيه
غير ان القيود الروسيه وهراميتها العسكريه
جديده المركزيه اسهمت في ابطال قواتها
باتخاذ قرارات ميدانيه سريعه ومستقله امر
حولها الى اهداف سهله امام وحدات اخرىنيه
اكثر استقلاليه وان كانت اقل عددا وعتادا
مشاهدينا ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه عبد
الجواد الرشد اهلا بك عبد الجواد اذا
الضربه التي تعرض لها الجيش الروسي كانت
قاسيه بكل المقاييس كيف كان صداها في
الداخل الروسي
مرحبا احمد نعم صحيح صحيح ما تقول هي
تربيه قاسيه من العيار الثقيل تعرضت لها
موسكو مع بدايه العام الجديد لكن ما خفيه
على كثيرين ولم تعلن عنهم وذكر رسميا الا
ان التقارير عسكريه طبعا تطرقت لهذا الشيء
ان كانت محليه وان كانت غربيه بان الضربه
الاخرانيه على هذه المنطقه في دنيتك حدثت
ليله في يعني في اليوم الاخير من العام
الماضي مع بدايه اليوم الجديد يعني
الروايه الرسميه تتحدث عن ان الجنود كانوا
يرسلون طبعا تهنئه بالعام الجديد الى
ذويهم في مناطق مختلفه همم طبعا هذا الشيء
ما اتحدث عنه الخبراء والمحللين العسكريين
بالذات في البلاد وليس السياسي فقط خلال
اليومين الماضيين وهو ما يبرر طبعا
التصعيد الكبير الذي تنجريه موسكو بما يخص
العمليات العسكريه في الاراضي العسكريه
لاحظنا طبعا انا بيان وزاره الدفاع يتحدث
تحييد اكثر من 350 شخصا في اليوم الاول من
العام الجديد وفي اليوم الثاني طبعا
التحيد وصل الى قرابه 180 شخصا بالاضافه
الى طرب والاسف وتعطيل العديد من النقاط
يعني العسكريه اتبع القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه الا انه صدى هذا الموضوع هنا
في الارض الروسيه في الواقع في المجتمع في
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي هو كبير طبعا
باعتبار ان هؤلاء الجنود هم من الذين تم
دعوتهم هي التعبئه الجزئيه التي اجرتها
موسكو خلال الفتره الماضيهم وصلوا الى
معسكر لتوزيعهم ايضا طبعا هناك بعض
التقارير تتحدث عن ان مستودع للاسلحه كان
يتواجد بجانب ذلك المعسكر الذي ارادت من
خلاله موسكو توزيع الجنود على نقاط طبعا
المواجهه في الجبهه وفي الخط الاول مع
الاراضي الاكرانيا لذلك الوضع طبعا هو في
تصعيد خطير كما نلاحظ ان نتحدث مع الناس
هنا في على المدينه او من سوريا
يعني كثير من المراقبين يعتبرون ان الجيش
الروسي ارتكب اخطاء فادي في خلال هذه
الحرب خاصه واخر هذه الاخطاء طبعا ما حصل
فيما كفك في ليله راس السنه كما تفضل هل
يتم تحميل وزاره الدفاع المسؤوليه حول ما
جرى هل هناك مطالبات بالمحاسبه او اجراء
تغييرات على مستوى وزاره الدفاع مثلا او
قياده العسكريه بسوره العامه
احمد لم يعني هناك من يتحدث عن ان التقصير
موجود بما يخص العمليه العسكريه الروسيه
في الاراضي الاوكرانيه والجميع يذكر طبعا
الموضوع الذي خرج به رمضان قادر الرئيس
الشيشان الذي يعني تبني قوته هناك بلاء من
خلال هذه الحرب خلال الاعمال القتاليه لكن
حتى هذه اللحظه لم تظهر اي مطالبه طبعا
بمحاسبه وزاره الدفاع او بمحاسبه اجهاض
بالرغم من وجود خروقات طبعا يعني نحن
تواجدنا على الارض في تلك المعارك طبعا
معرفه تواجد اماكن الجنود من استخدامهم
لجوالاتهم او هاتفهم المحموله هو شيء صعب
للغايه تقنيه لا يمكن يعني الوصول لتلك
النقاط مكان استخدام الهواتف المحموله
طبعا الحديث العديد منهم يحمل طبعا الجهه
الغربيه باستخدام الاقمار الصناعيه الخاصه
في التقاط صور وتزويدها لجانب الغربي ايضا
طبعا مراكز الاستقبال التي همم يعني كانت
قري من الاماكن التي استخدم بها الجنود
هواتفهم الجوال لعب الدورا كبيرا في تحديد
اماكن وجودهم لذلك طبعا الوضع هو خطير
نوعا ما كما يتحدث الروس الوضع الان في
تصعيد كبير الاعمال العسكريه كما نرى على
نطاق واسع وطبعا معلوماتها وما ياتي من
هناك والتقارير الوارده تتحدث عن ان
المنطقه مقبله على حرب طبعا اصعب
من هذا
شكرا معنا مراسل العربيه
في المقابل المشاهدين اعلنت هيئه الاركان
في الجيش الاوكراني تنفيذه ثلاثه عشره
هجوم صاروخيا مدفوعيا على مواقع القوه
الروسيه خلال 24 ساعه واشار جيشركاني في
بيانه الى احباط محاولات روسيه في 15
منطقه بدون هاسك واتهم الجيش الاوكراني
روسيا بقصف مناطق ماهولات الضفه اليمنى من
نهر النيبرو بخيرسون مؤكدا ان تهديد ضربات
الجويه والصاروخيه الروسيه عربيه التحتيه
الحيويه في جميع انحاء اوكرانيا لا يزال
مستمر
معهد دراسات الحرب الامريكي يكشف تناقص
كميات الذخائر لدى القوات الروسيه في
اوكرانيا حسب اخر التقييم للحرب في
اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الصحفي محمد البابا اهلا بك سيد البابا
معنا في هذه النشره وبدايه هل يحتفل
اوكرانيون بهذه الضربه الكبيره للجيش
الروسي في ماكيكا
نعم يعني وانا يعني بالامس تكلمت عن ما
حصل في هذه الضربه التي يراها الجانب
الاوكراني ضرب نوعيه اولا ضرب نوعيه
استخباراتيا للجيش الاوكراني الذي يعني
علم بعض التفاصيل ووجه ضرب دمرت مصنع
الاسلحه وقاعده عسكريه وبحسب ما يتداول في
وسائل الاعلام الاوكرانيه واوصاف وزاره
الدفاع الاوكرانيه ان اعداد القتلى تتجاوز
ال 400 الى 600 جندي روسي كانوا
نعم
فقدنا الصوت والاتصال معه السيد محمد
البابا شكرا
القضايا الخلافيه والعمل على زياده التوتر
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد اتهم تركيا
اليونان بتقريب الاجتماعات والمحادثات
الراميه الى بحث القضايا خلافي بينهما
واوضح وزير الدفاع التركي خلاص يا اكار ان
بعض السياسيين اليونانيين يحاولون عن وعي
زياده التوتر واعتبر عكار ان اليونان
تحاول تجسيد مشكلتها مع تركيا على انها
مشكله بين تركيا وحلف شمال اطلسي
والولايات المتحده والاتحاد الاوروبي
الى الاحتجاجات في ايران
المعنيه بحقوق الانسان في ايران عن ارتفاع
عدد ضحايا الاحتجاجات الى
516 شخصا بينهم 70 على الاقل دون سن
الثامنه عشر تقرير
النظام اعتقلت اكثر من تسعه عشره الف
متضاهر في مئه واحد 160 مدينه ايرانيه كما
اكل التغيير
244 جامعه في البلاد شهد الاحتجاجات
طلابيه ضد النظام الايراني هذا ونشر
النظام الايراني مجددا قواته العسكريه في
مدينه الجواند الكرديه في ظل حاله غليان
تشهدها المدينه حقيبه قتل عناصر امنيه
لمحتاج السبت الماضي ولتزام تطوره مع
استعدادات اهالي المدينه لاقامه مراسم
اربعينيه سبعه قتله سقط في المسيرات
الاحتجاليه بنيران افراد الامن اشهر
الماضي كما تشهد مدينه مهابات الكرديه
بدورها تجمعات شعبيه لاحياء اربعينيه
ضحايا رصاص الامن الشهر الماضي
كشفت مصادر عن اعتزامي بريطانيا الاعلان
رسميا عن تصنيف الحرس الثوري الايراني
منظمه الارهابيه على خلفيه اعتقال
المملكه المتحده بسبب احتياجات ضد النظام
اشاره الى ان هذه الخطوه تلقى دعم وزراء
الامني والداخليه مضيفه ان القرار يعني
تجريم الانتماء للحوادث الثوري او
المشاركه باجتماعاته او رفع شعرته في
بريطانيا وفقا لصحيفه ياتي هذا الاجراء
بعد اكثر من 10 مؤامرات للحرس الثوري
الايراني لاختطاف او قتل اشخاص في
بريطانيا خلال العام الماضي
هذا هو وشدد كبير المفاوضين الايرانيين
علي باقيدي على اصدار بلاده على موقفها
بضروره رفع العقوبات للوصول الى اتفاق
نووي وقال بقلي في تصريحات لوكاله ايرنا
الايرانيه ان مسار المفاوضات النوويه لم
ينقطع ونحافظ على الثماريته
وصل خط الفقري لكل اسره مكونه من اربعه
افراد في ايران الى 188 دولارا واكثر من
ثلث سكان ايران تحت خط الفقر وفق صحيفه
اعتماد الايرانيه الصحيفه ايضا ان خط
الفقر ارتفع في العام الماضي في ايران
بنسبه 50% وان ارقام خط الفقر في العاصمه
ايران اعلى بكثير من المناطق الاخرى
ذكر المرصد السوري لحقوق الانسان طلب
لا تخفي دوائر استراتيجيه وامنيه في
اسرائيل خلقها من امكان ان تشهد العلاقه
مع البيت الابيض توترات على خلفيه هيمنه
وزراء متطرفين على اجهزه حكومه انتياه
الجديده وان يقود ذلك في حال انفجار الوضع
مع الفلسطينيين الى زعزعه الدعم الامريكي
التلقائي الذي تتمتع به اسرائيل منذ عقود
حتى فيما يتعلقوا بمواجهه الملف الايراني
وما يحمله من تهديدات بنظري اسرائيل
لا تغير ينتظر في سياسه الحكومه
الاسرائيليه الجديده بخصوص استمرار
الغارات على ما تسميه اسرائيل التموضع
الايراني في سوريا او مواجهه المشروع
النووي الايراني
مواجهه مع الفلسطينيين ما قد يؤثر على
العلاقه مع الاداره الامريكيه الديمقراطيه
حتى في التعاون على مواجهه ايران
لعمليه التي تحدثنا عنها والتي نحذر منها
عمليه تهديد الدعم الامريكي الاوتوماتيكي
لاسرائيل على المدى الطويل واحتمال المسي
بالعلاقات الخاصه مع الامريكيين وفي
الخلفيه انتقادات الديمقراطيين لنتنياهو
ورغم ان اسرائيل اجرد مناورات فرديه واخرى
مشتركه مع الامريكيين ودول اخرى حاكه
استهداف المنشات النوويه الايرانيه الى ان
القدره العسكريه علشان هجوم اسرائيليا
منفرد لم تكتمل بعد معضله اسرائيل ان
استراتيجيتها باتت تعليقه منعت الاتفاق
النووي مع ايران لكن بدون وجود خطه دوليه
او حتى اسرائيليه جاهزه بينما تهرب طهران
نحو القنبله النوويه تخصيدا لليورانيوم
الجمهوريه بين الاداره الامريكيه وهمم
اسرائيل في نظره الى الملف الايراني والى
طريقه التعامل مع هذا التهديد علاقه
نتنياه الفاتره باداره بيض وتشكيكه فيها
بتاكيده مؤخرا فقط بانه لن يشاركها امر
الضربه لا خشيه من تسريب الامر لمنعها قد
يترك اسرائيل وحدها في المواجهه الى حد
كبير تم ادراك استراتيجيه في اسرائيل بان
استهداف المنشات النوويه الايرانيه يحتاج
دعم وتسليح النوعيه الامريكيا لتنفيذه
بنجاح والا فان التلويحه بالضرب يصبح
تلويحا بمسدس فارغ من الطلقه زياد حلبي
العربيه القدس الغربيه
باقتحام وزير الامن الاسرائيلي مع من تيار
اليمين الاثمار باحات المسجد الاقصى وصفته
باستفزاز غير مسبوق كما اكلت ان هذا
اقتحام شرعنه لمزيد من الاقتحامات
والسباحه المسجد الاقصى من قبل المستوطنين
وحامله الحكومه نتنياهم مسؤوليه اعوامها
اقتحمى صباح اليوم باحات المسجد الاقصى
وسط حمايه المشدده من الشرطه الاسرائيليه
وبدون اعلان المسبقه
ايه المشاهدين اقتحمت قواتنا الكبيره ايضا
من الجيش الاسرائيلي مدينه الجليل ومخيمها
واعتقلت فلسطينيين اثنين اخوات ذكر مراس
العربي انه وحدات الاسرائيليه تسللت الى
جنين
ومخيمها وتبيعها اقتحام وعدد كبير من
اليات الجيش الاسرائيلي مشيرا الى مواجهه
دلعت بين الشبان والقوات الاسرائيليه في
عده مناطق اثناء عمليه الاقتحام من جهه
الاخرى ذكرت الصحه الفلسطينيه ان القوات
الاسرائيليه قتل الطفل الفلسطينيا خلال
التواهلها في مخيم الدهيشه جنوب بيت لحم
مشاهدينا معنا من القدس مراسله العربيه
زياد حلب اهلا بك زياد بدايه احنا الاسباب
التي دفعت وزير الامن الاسرائيليه
الاقتحام المسجد الاقصى وما اذا كانت هناك
ردود فعل رصده حتى اللحظه على ما حدث
اولا دان يبدا بالتاهب الاسرائيلي على
حدود قطاع غزه خشيه من احتمال اطلاق
صواريخ من قبل حركه حماس او الجهاد
الاسلامي ردا على اقتحام بن كبير صباح
اليوم للمسجد الاقصى المبارك عمليا عمليه
الاقتحام جاءت بعد نوع من همم
الخداع جزاء التعبير بن كبير كان اعلن بان
انه سيقتحم خلال اسابيع واشيع بان نتنياهو
ضرب منه همم التريث وما الى ذلك فهما بان
الاتحاد تاجل او الغيه همم لكن عمليا اتفق
الرجلان امس همم ليلا على هذا الاتحاد
بمشاو متشاور مع رئيس المخابرات الشباب
عام الشرطه الاسرائيليه همم وتم فعليا
صباح هذا اليوم مده ثلاثه 10 دقيقه عمليا
كان خاطفا جاء لتسجيل موقف من بني كبير
عمليا وهو الوزير الامن القومي والمعروف
عنه التطرف اراد ان يقول بانه لا يخضع
لتهديدات حركه حماس للتذكير فقط الحرب
الاخيره على قطاع غزه تسبب بها بنفيرا
عندما كان نائبا عندما اقتحم الشيخ جراح
والمسجد الاقصى وبالتالي لهذا هناك حال من
التاهب ردود الفعل توالت غاضبه من الفصائل
الفلسطينيه وايضا الرسميه
والتوقع ايضا ان يكون هناك التوتر في
العلاقه بين تل ابيب وعمان بسبب هذه
الزياره لان دول عربيه عده حذرت نتنياهو
من عدم القيام بذلك الشرطه ايضا الى سعاده
امنيه كبيره على حدود قطاع غزه ماذا عن
بقيه المناطق وما مستوى رد الذي يتوقعه
همم الاسرائيليون من الفلسطيني سواء من
الحركات او حتى من الشعب الفلسطيني وسوره
العامه
بطبيعه الحال الاوضاع منفجره اساسا بين
الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين او ردت في
المقدمه فقط في الخبر
تباعا مقتل ان اسرائيل قتلت فتن في بيت
لحم وهناك اقتحامات مستمره بهذا المعنى
هناك توتر قائم اصلا هذا الاقتحام يصب
الزيتا على النار بنظر الفلسطينيين الهم
الاكبر بالنسبه للاسرائيليين هو قضيه ماذا
سيفعل قطاع غزه او حركه حماس هل تطلق
صاروخا او اثنين على الاقل بشكل رمزي للرد
على بين كبير هذه هي المعذره الحقيقيه في
هذه المعادله عمليا حماس حولت منذ المره
الماضيه ان تضع معادله اقتحام الاقصى
والاوضاع في القدس تنعكس في الضفه وحرف في
قطاع غزه وما الى ذلك وبالتالي اسرائيل
عمليا نشرت بطاريات قبه حديديه في وقت
المصباب وهي في حال تاهب عمليا لكن لا
نستطيع ان تتاهل ان كان هناك
يكون اطلاق صواريخ ام ان الامور
ستستمر هادئه نسبيه شكرا لك من القدس كنت
معنا مراسل العربيه زياد حلبي تحيه زياد
القائم باعمال وزير التجاره لحكومه طالبان
نور الدين عزيزي انا طالبان ستسع لجلب
استثمارات الروسيه وصينيه وايرانيه الى
افغانستان الا ان هذا اثار حفيظه الشارع
الافغاني التفاصيل الى في التغيير التالي
[تصفيق]
رغم سلسله المتاعب السياسيه التي اثرتها
قرارات طالبان الاخيره والتحديات الامنيه
التي يفرضها تنظيم داعش تطمح الحركه الى
تعزيز الاستثمار في افغانستان وتحقيق ما
تراه اكتفاء ذاتيا
ويبدو ان مسؤولي طالبان الذين يعانون من
ازمه اقتصاديه خانقه فقمها قرار منع
النساء من العمل في المنظمات الدوليه
يرهلون على دور صيني وروسي وايراني في
اقتصاد البلاد
لدينا اقبال على الاستثمار في مجال
الزراعه خصوصا ايران التي تريد الاستثمار
في الاراضي الزراعيه والمياه الافغانيه
وكذلك الصين تريد الاستثمار في الزراعه
والثروه الحيوانيه وغيرها الا ان هذا لا
يبدو حلا واقعيا اقله على المدى القريب
وحتى المتوسط في الصين ورغم بعض المساعدات
العينيه البسيطه لا تبدو مستعده في الوقت
الراهن على اي دور اقتصادي وخصوصا بعد
استهداف عدد من المستثمرين الصينيين بهجوم
انه داعش على فندق وسط العاصمه كابل في
ديسمبر الماضي
المنطق الامني نفسه ينسحب على روسيا التي
كان من الممكن ان تشكل جهه مانحه ومستثمره
في افغانستان
لكنها استهدفت ايضا بهجوم على السفاره
الروسيه في كابل في شهر سبتمبر من العام
فيما يخص ايران فان تصريحات عزيزي تناقض
رؤيه قياده طالبان تجاه طهران التي ترى
فيها خطرا على حكمها واملها لاسيما محاوله
ايران استغلال ورقه اقليه الهزار
الافغانيه
وتواجه حكومه طالبان تحديا خارجيا اخر
يتمثل في عدم اعتراف في غالبيه المجتمع
الدولي في حكمها اضافه الى عقوبات تعوق
تطوير عمل القطاع المصرفي في افغانستان
محمد السيف العربيه
نشاطره مستمره مشاهدينا وفيها بعض الفاصل
استقبال تاريخي لرونالدو وفريق النصر
السعودي يقدمه اليوم بجماهيره
نائب رئيس مجلس السياده يعلن محاوله لقلب
النظام الحكم بافريقيا الوسطى من داخل
السودان
الجيش
كبير المفاوضين الايرانيين يشددوا على
ضروره رفع العقوبات الوصول الى احياء
الاتفاق النووي
وزير الامن الاسرائيلي يقتحم باحات الاقصى
بدون اعلان مسابقه وسلطه والفصائل تدين
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد اعلنت وزاره
النقل التونسيه
على شبكه الحافلات والمترو اثار مع شركه
نقل تونس بتحديد موعد صرف نهايه السنه
العاملين في الشركه وكان موظفوا شركه
النقل الحكوميه نفذوا اضرابا احتجاجا على
التاخر في دفع المكافات والاجور بدوره
تعاهد الاتحاد العام التونسي الشغل بتنظيم
السيره الاحتجاجات على ما وصفه بتهميش
الحكومه للشركات العامه
للمرافق العموميه والتصدي لكل من يسعى الى
ضرب السمنه الاجتماعيه في البلاد مؤكدا
انه له وجود لاحد فوق القانون وحذر الرئيس
سعيد بان اجهزه الدوله لن تبقى مكتوبه
حريصه على تطبيق القانون والحفاظ على
المؤسسات وعلى حق المواطنين في الامن بقدر
حرصها على الحقوق والحريات
حضر اطباء اورام السرطان في السودان من
نقص الادويه والجرعات الكيميائيه الخاصه
بمرضاهم في وقت اكد وزير الصحه الاتحادي
انقطاع بعض الادويه لعدم توفير تموينات
الماليه لشركات الادويه الخارجيه ورصده
العربيه شكوى اسر المرضى من انقطاع
الدوائي بلا سابق اعلان تقرير
الالم والقهر كل ما حان موعد قطاع الدواء
في السودان بلا سابق انذار
فتاخر جرعه المصابين بداء السرطان قد تقود
الى انتكاسا هنا ومنذ اربعه اشهر يتقاسم
المرضى اسم المرض ويختلفون في تفاصيله
واسم الدواء المفقود في ادويه السرطان
بانواعه والماساه الاكبر وان الاطفال
يمثلون نسبه 70%
للاسف الشديد يعني اي نقص
اي نقص في الدعاء اي تاخير في الجمعه
ده للمريض قلبي ياخذ علاج اصلا تمام
الانتكاسه معناها المرض الثاني للاسف
الشديد العلاج منه زاني صعب جدا جدا
فرهما الاوجاع الجسديه والنفسيه الا انا
اوجاع الفكريه في كيفيه الحصول على دواء
غير موجود زادت من رحله امامهم صعوبه في
توفير الدواء يلا نحن ما قادرين او حتى لو
لقيناهما قادرين نشتريهم لان مشينا
الصيدليات لقينا غالي الواحد الواحد
[موسيقى]
العلاج
انا كنت في المستشفى قبل ثلاثه قبل سنتين
وانا داير العلاج
مستشفى ثانيه
مستمر
هذه الشركات اللي اتوقع انه الوفره
وان يتوفر في السوق السوداء مشكله اكبر
الارتفاع سعره انما لسوء تخزينه الذي يخشى
منه الاطباء وهو ما يجعل المريض في رحله
متعبتين من الالم والقلق لين يعقوب
العربيه الخرطوم
والان الى وقفه ما اخبار الاقتصاد
اسواق المنطقه في ثالث جلسه لتداولات سوق
الاسهم السعوديه والثانيه لباقي الاسواق
الخليجيه السوق يرتفع للجلسه الثالثه على
التوالي بالسعوديه نحن قريبون او فوق
10000 نقطه هذا يمثل ارتداد بحول 600 نقطه
من عندنا مستوى كان نوصله المؤشر ديسمبر
الماضي دبي على ثبات بالوقت الحاضر الى
حوالي 100 مليون درهم حتى الساعه بيع ابو
ظبي اقل من 900 مليون درهم حتى ساعه قيام
الدوله
اكبر 15 شركه بابو ظبي على ارتفاع باربعه
عشر مئويه مؤشر الكويت الاول على تراجع
اليوم السوق القطري على ارتفاع باربعه
اشهر النقطه المئويه غدا جلسه متباينات
السعوديه عن بعض الاسهم التي نتبعها وفره
وسدافكو في توقيع اتفاقيه بين الشركتين ب
11.4 مليون ريال تقوم بموجبها وفره بانتاج
مونتاج وتعبئته تحت على خاصه لصدفكم لصالح
صدفكو ولو انه مده العقد سته اشهر ولكن
لاحظوا الارتفاعات على الثامن سنترز من
بعد ما كانت اعلنت توزيعات نقديه يوم امس
اليوم الخبر هو دعوه للجمعيه العموميه
للتصويت على اصدار على برنامج انشاء
برنامج للسكوك باربعه ونص مليار ريال
ويمكن الاصدارات تكون اما اصدار واحد او
عده اصدارات بالفتره القادمه لوبرا في
اليوم على بعض تراجع بثمن اعشار النقطه
المئويه ولكنها الاكثر تداولا بالقيمه
بالسوق السعودي ارامكو على ميل للارتفاع
اليوم عند 32 ريال و20 هلا وفره شفناها
عذيب للالات واصل تسجيل المكاسب من بعد
العقد اللي حصلت عليه يوم امس والارتفاع
هو ليومين متتاليين على سهم عجيب الراجحي
ايضا على حجم تداولات عالي ومرتفع بنصف
النقطه المئويه اليوم بدبي خلينا نشوف ما
هي الاسهم الضغطه ولو انه كما ذكرت احسن
من التداول ضعيفه الاكثر تداولا ملفت انه
مصرف عجمان يرتفع ب 2.5% سالك على ثبات
اليوم بدون اي تغيير ولكن عليها نشاط من
حيث احجام التداول الاعمار للتطوير واعمار
العقاريه في تباين بين السهمين الخليج
للملاحه عليها حجم تدولات عاليه اليوم لو
انها متراجعه بواحد فاصل سبعه بالمئه
عندما اقول عالي اندرس فاكتف كل التداولات
بالسوق 100 مليون درهم بابوظبي ارتفاع ب14
النقطه المئويه اليوم العالميه القابضه هي
انشط سهم ولكنها على تراجع المرتفعين هما
مارت بلاي طاقه ويدعمان السوق مالت فلاي
وطاقه ابو ظبي للموانئ من الاكثر تداولا
مرتفعه او الفضاء ايضا هذه التي تدعم مؤشر
السوق للارتفاع بالكويت عندنا جلسه نزوليه
اليوم ذكر انه بال22 كانت الاسهم القياديه
ارتفعت ب 6.5% المؤشر الاول للمؤشر الرئيس
اداء باقي السوق غير القياديات كان على
تراجع باربعه فاصل سبعه بالمئه على مدار
العام الماضي اليوم نبدا الجلسات العام
الجديد على تراجع بالكويت بيتك من الاسم
الضغطه هو الاكثر تداولا وعقارات الكويت
ولكن اجل التي الصناعات الوطنيه على
ارتفاع وطني على ارتفاع نظره مشاهدينا على
اسعار او هذا مؤشر سوق قطر على ميل
للارتفاع من بعد سنه سيئه بالعام الماضي
المؤشر قطر خسر ثمانيه بالمئه رغم
ارتفاعات اسعار الغاز والايرادات الحكوميه
الاكثر نشاطا بقطر الريان شركه قطر لصناعه
الالمنيوم همم الاستثمار القابضه مزايا
قطر وطبيه كلها الاسهم الاكثر تداولاهم
كلهم مرتفعه وقفه مع اسعار النفط التي
تسجل ارتفاعات اليوم بالفعل فينا نعتبر
انه يقول جلسات العام لانه يوم امس كانت
السوق اسواق الطاقه مغلقه وكان فقط
الاسواق الاوروبيه عامله يوم امس وبستثناء
بريطانيا وسويسرا اليوم بالفعل تبدا
تداولات على كل الاسواق العالميه اسيا
عادات للتداول ما عدا اليابان اليابان
تبقى مغلقه والولايات المتحده تعود الى
التداول اليوم اولى جلسات 2023 الصوره
ايجابيه بشكل عام اسيا كانت بدات على
النزول صباحا عكست اتجاهها الصعودا بدون
تفسير يعني عم بنحكي هو يتفاؤل بانه اعاده
فتح الاقتصاد الصيني قد ترفع الطلب هذا
العام ومنه الطلب على النفط ولذلك نرى
النفط يرتفع وهذا الهاتف عاد للارتفاع
باثنين بالمئه اليوم بالجلسه الاسيويه من
بعد بدايه سلبيه واوروبا على ارتفاع للج
فرصه ثانيه اعلى توالي فاذا نكتفي بهذا
القدر للان اعود اليك احمد الان وانا القى
المشاهدين في الاسواق العربيه بعد قليل
ان تكون الولايات المتحده بصدد مناقشه
اجراء تدريبات النوويه مشتركه مع كوريا
الجنوبيه مناقضا بذلك تصريحات نظيره
الكوري الجنوبي وقال رئيس كوريا الجنوبيه
في وقت سابق بلاده واشنطن تناقشاني
امكانيه تنظيم تدريبات المشتركه باستخدام
القدرات النوويه الامريكيه ونقل صحيفه عن
رئيس كوريا الجنوبيه قوله ان التخطيط لهذه
التدريبات المشتركه يهدف الى زياده فاعليه
ردع الموسع الامريكي وان واشنطن ابدى
ترحبا كبيرا بهذه الفكره وجهه تصريحاته
بعد دعوته لاستعداد للحرب بقدرات ساحقه
بعد عام شهد عددا قياسيا من تجارب اطلاق
الصواريخ من جانبه سوريا
التوترات سياسيه وعسكريه بين الصين
وتايوان بلغ ذروتها العام الماضي خاصه بعد
زياره رئيسه مجلس النواب الامريكي
ومع بدايه العام الجديد رصد التقارير صحفي
ارتفاع معدلات النشاط العسكري الصيني قرب
طيوان وذلك في ظل حاله ترقب لما قد يحدث
من تطورات بين بردين خلال هذا العام
تتمسك الصين بسياسه وحده اراضيها وانها
جزء لا يتجزا في مواجهه محاولات تايوان
للتخلص من التبعيه لبكينا انطلاقا من حق
تقرير المصير
خلاف ادى الى استمرار التوتر بين الجانبين
بالزيادته خلال عام 2022 في منطقه بحر
تايوان والخط الفاصل المعروف باسم منطقه
اديس للدفاع الجوي وهي منطقه تشمل مساحه
اكبر بكثير والمطلوب من كل طائره اجنبيه
تحلق في داخلها التعريف عن نفسها للسلطات
الجويه المحليه سواء للصين
وخلال العام الماضي سجلت العلاقات بين
الصين وتايوان اكبر تدهور لها منذ تسلم
الرئيس السلطه وما زاد من هوته ولجوء
تايوان لاستقبال وفود برلمانيه من الدول
الغربيه كان ابرزها وصول رئيسه مجلس
النواب الامريكي نانسي
فكففت الصين نشاطتها العسكريه قربه تايوان
واطلقت اكبر مناوراتهم منذ سنوات مقارنه
بالاعوام السابقه وفقا لوكاله الانباء
الفرنسيه
حيث بلغ عدد الطائرات التي نشرتها الصين
قربه تايوان في عام
طائره مقارنه ب 960 طائره في عام 2021 و
بين عامي 2021 و 2022 ازداد عدد توغل
الطائرات المقاتله الصينيه باكثر من الضعف
من
538 طائره الى
1141 طائره وارتفع عدد القادسات ومنها اتش
6 ذات القدرات النوويه من 60 الى ما يزيد
على مئه قادفه
وفي ظل هذه الارقام الاخذه في الارتفاع
يبقى خلاف تايوان الصين قائما كما هو
مصحوبا بحاله ترقب دولي واقليمي خاصه مع
تمسك الولايات المتحده بدعم عسكري
واقتصادي لتايوان راغبه في الانفصال
وبالنسبه للصين غالبا ما تكون التوهلات
الجويه وسيله للتعبير عن الاستياء من
سياسات تايوان علي السمان العربيه
يتسلم الجمهوريون اليوم الغربيه
باغلبيه المقاعد في مجلس الشيوخ ومع هذا
التغيير يستعد البيت الابيض لمواجهه لا
مفر منها مع الحزب الجمهوريه الذي توعد
بمحاسبه الرئيس الامريكي
تتراوح بين التمويل الحرب في اوكرانيه الى
المنافسه مع الصين والانسحاب من افغانستان
باضافه الى ساعي الجمهوريه لاغلاق
التحقيقات ضد الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
في مقابل
نجل الرئيس الامريكي
متابعينا نتابع اذا هذه الصور المباشره
لجثمان اسطوره كره القدم
الى مقبره قريبه ومن المتوقع اذا مشاهدينا
ان يحضر الرئيس البرازيلي الجديد لويس
ان يحضر الى هذا المكان هذا الرئيس الذي
ادى اليمين الاحد الماضي ربما سيحضر الى
ملعب قبل وقت قصير من اخراج
مشاهدينا طبعا توفي يوم الخميس الماضي عن
عمر 82 عاما بعد معركه مع السرطان وهو
اللاعب الوحيد الذي فاز بكاس العالم ثلاثه
مرات
مشاهدينا بعد اذنكم في متابعه لهذه الصور
المباشره لجثمان اسطوره كره القدم بلاي في
سانتوس بملعب فيرابيل ميرو قبل حمل النعش
في شوارع سانتوس الى مقبره قريبه وكما
ذكرنا يتوقع ان يحضر اذا الرئيس البرازيلي
الجديد لولا السيلفا الذي ادى اليمين
الاحد الماضي ان يحضر الى ملعب الميرو قبل
وقت قصير من اخراج المحشي من الملعب بيليق
اسطوره القدم البرازيليه المعروف مشاهدينا
توفي طبعا يوم الخميس الماضي عن عمر نهز
اثنين وثمانين عاما بعد معركه قاسيه مع
مرض السرطان
ويعتبر طبعا هو اللاعب الوحيد الذي فاز
بكاس العالم
لثلاثه مرات
[موسيقى]
ذكرت صحيفه
سيقدم عرضا من اللقاحات كورانا مجانا الى
الصين لمساعدتها على احتواء تفشي المرض
ويعتبر العرض من جهود مفوضيه الاتحاد
الاوروبي للصحه للاستجابه لموجه كورونا
التي تجتاح الصين ولتعبها في تنفيذ
السياسه الصفر كوفيت
عربه
التي فرضتها بعض الدول تجاه دخول الوافدين
الصينيين تحسبا من تشاركونا وقال المتحدث
باسم
الخارجيه تتخذ اجراءات مناسبه ضد الدول
التي فرضت القيود على الوافدين الصينيين
مشيرا الى انها افتكرت الاساس العلمي وغير
مباراه ايضا
حسب مؤشر ستاندرد اند بورزا فقد سجل
القطاع الخاص غير النفطي في السعوديه نموا
في الربع الاخير من عام 2022 مدفوع البنت
عاش قوي
وطلبيات استثمار القطاع الخاص في مجال
الزراعيه في جده انحاء السعوديه هو من
عوام التي تسهم في الدفع بعجله الاغتصاب
وتنويع الانشطه المدره للدخل بعيدا عن
قطاع الطاقه مثال من منطقه الاحساء
لا تفرز الحبوب تعمل بكل طاقتها ايزانا
ببدا موسم حصاد الارز الحساوي الذي انطلق
في محافظه الاحساء في المنطقه الشرقيه
زكي السالم فتح ابواب من سرعته لاستقبال
الجميع سواء من محبي الارز او العيش
الحساوي او من من يريدون التعرف على هذا
المنتج التراثي
1900 سنه قلت
اني احب كل هواي وهذا المنتج فاخذت هذه
المساحه فالحمد لله صار الانتاج
محاولات استزراع العيش الحساوي خارج
السعوديه لم تكن موفقه
بالصين
قول لي الاحسائيين لكل مواطن سعودي يفتخر
ان هذا المنتج
جرب في دول العالم ولا نجح الا في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه
بلونه الاحمر وقيمته الغذائيه العاليه حيث
يحتوي على فوائد صحيه كبيره من الحديد
وهذا ما اكتشفه زوار مزرعه السالم الذي
حارس ان يكرم ضيوفه
يحتاج هذا النوع من المحاصيل الى عنايه
خاصه لان زراعته تبدا في فصل الصيف
من المساحه اللي انت تزرعها 40 يوم بعدين
نشيلها
ننجفه وبعدين نوديه في الاماكن الثانيه
هذا المنتج الزراعي في الحفاظ على الموروث
الثقافي السعودي فانه من خلال الاستثمار
فيه وتطوير تقنيه زراعته يساهم القطاع
الخاص في رؤيه 20 30 العربيه
وصل اللاعب البرتغالي كريستيانو رونالدو
الى العاصمه السعوديه الرياض رفقه عائلته
التمهيدا للمشاركه مع ناصر السعودي وينتظر
ان يقدم النادي لاعبه الجديد الى الجماهير
اليوم في ملعب مرصد بارك وسط حضور
الجماهري واعلامي كبير من داخل السعوديه
وخارجها ومن المنتظران يوقي كريستيانو
رونالدو خلال حفله التقديم كلمه يخاطب بها
جماهير ناديه الجديد
صفقه انتقال اللاعب البرتغالي كريستيانو
رونالدو الى النادي العاصميه حتى بدات
الانذار تتجه الى
المتجر الرسمي لنادي النصر وهذا احد
المناظر
لمشجعين فرحين جدا بالحصول على تي شيرت
كريستيانو رونالدو في المتجر الرسمي الذي
تباع فيه همم
الفنلات والتيشرتات الخاصه بكريستيانو
رونالدو بالاضافه الى المتجر الرسمي هنالك
متجر الكترونيه بيع في هذا التيشيرت
لكريستيانو رونالدو بدا من صفقه الانتقال
من اعلانها مباشره تم وضع عدد من
الفانيلات الخاصه بكريستيانو رونالدو مع
نادي النصر لانها نفذ بشكل كامل فبالتالي
يتم الاستعانه
بطريقه اخرى
لتوفير هذا التيشيرت للمشجعين باسرع وقت
ممكن الطريقه اخرى ان ياتي المشجع مباشره
ويشتري تيشيرت او فانيلا بدون رقم وبدون
اسم اي لاعب بعد ذلك ينتقل الى المرحله
همم الثانيه وهي مرحله الطباعه وفيها
يتواجد عدد من موظفي المتجر الرسمي ويطبع
اسم كريستيانو ورقمه مباشره ليستلمها
المشجع لضافه الى تواجد الموقع همم
الالكتروني الذي تتوفر في التيشيرتات
قريبا ولكن حتى الان همم لم يتم توفير عدد
كبير من التيشرتات وهي ليست متوفره حتى
هذه اللحظه الكثير من الجماهير يطالبون
بتوفيرها باقرب همم لحظه وبعدد ضخم من همم
ارقام لكي يتسنى لكل محبي ومشجعي
كريستيانو رونالدو الحصول على هذا
التيشيرت وهمم
وشراي مباشره سواء من متجر الكترونيه وحتى
من متجر النادي
عبد المحسن الحربي العربيه الريال
نائب رئيس مجلس السياده يعلن ارسال محاوله
لقلب النظام الحكم بافريقيا الوسطى من
داخل السودان
للقوات الروسيه في 15 منطقه
العقوبات للوصول الى احياء الاتفاق النووي
وزير الامن الاسرائيليه يقتحم باحات
الاقصى بدون اعلان مسبق والسلطه والفصائل
تدين
نهايته هذه الساعه الاخباريه مشاهدينا
الشكر لحسن المتابع ويا المدينه
[موسيقى]